if you are content happy if you are
centered everything will flow to you you
don't have to go and grab something
things will come your way
do you see what I'm saying this is why
this world is called Maya you know why I
am Maya means when you try to go and
grab it it runs away from you if we try
to possess if you try to grab something
it just runs away and if you are stable
still content within yourself
they all run towards you you know I say
we are all global people we have to
learn something from everywhere in the
world and I would say we have to learn
the precision and the timeliness and the
commitment from Germans the world should
learn I always say the perfection is
always Germans lady cassis is always
from England
the mannerism maitika sees you know and
business and salesmanship Americans
teamwork from Japanese Japanese are so
good in teamwork
similarly spirituality from India human
value of spirituality compassion
it all comes from India so we need to
get the best from every part of the
world and the next coming generation
will see that sort of global human being
of course technology has shrunk the
whole world into a global village today
through technology in one second we
communicate with the whole world in the
same way if we can tune of our minds to
that simplicity the innocence to caring
and sharing we will find the whole world
as one family the global family you just
watched two amazing clips from Sri Sri
Ravi Shankar take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]